speaking of Justin Waller he had a
question for you his question was has
your view of the red pill Community
changed over time and if so how and the
second question is when are you coming
to Miami
is he on your phone right now no no he
uh we we we discussed this yesterday
um yeah I like Justin so
I'll be I'll be down in Miami at some
point like I know he's down there and
I've had a lot of invites to do podcasts
there so
um yeah Justin I will see you my man but
um my view of the red pill Community
okay well I'm gonna rephrase that my
view of the manosphere has changed I
view it as the Mano swap now yeah um I
don't like it I really think that it's
um it is primarily filled with uh people
that aren't good men or good at being
men that being said I think there's a
lot of good information and you have to
be good at separating the wheat from the
chaff and I don't think the average Joe
out there that's looking for help or
that's stuck you know in his life is has
has got the skills or the tools to do
that so it's a complex question yeah my
uh my producer is agreeing with you 100
yeah so it's one of these situations
where like if I were to explain the
concept of gravity to somebody who
builds an electromagnet you know a
hydroelectric Dam then they're
generating electricity they're using
gravity for that purpose if someone else
uses gravity to drop a nuclear bomb
they're using gravity for a different
purpose I feel like red pill or the
ideas from evolutionary psychology or a
technology that you can use but you can
use it for good or for bad and if you
need it for a justification to hate
other people or to become very evil or
angry or whatever or just the worst for
me is the justification on why your life
didn't turn out the way it was supposed
to because the the whole world is tilted
against you I feel like that is where it
kind of gets harmful for me like what
you said before like I If women wait at
the finish line
women uh you know and [__] the winners
that to me was not uh what a criticism
of women it was a criticism of me I need
to become a [__] winner that's what
that statement meant to me yeah that's
what yeah that's what winners will think
but those were the victim mindset will
think oh well I'll never make it to the
finish line so the game is rigged
against me I'm I'm just gonna lose so
why bother even playing yeah are you
when you say this are you referring to
like red pill rage is that what you mean
before because you said I'm one of the
things I'm skipping to the end of your
book but in the last chapter I thought I
really appreciated you said let's not
blame women for this like I think it's
just a function of natural selection
women have to have a way to sort
whichever men are alphas or betas now I
think there's an evolutionary mismatch I
think the way they choose like choosing
people who look like post Malone is kind
of weird to me or Takashi 69 I think
there's some sort of evolutionary
mismatch here but do you is that what
you're talking about before when you say
the Mana swamp
yeah the
where do you I mean this is a deep
Rabbit Hole brother like where do you
want to start with a man of swamp uh so
so let's let's go specifically into
angry men or do you feel like there's
some men that are like I I don't think
red pill this is going to be really
controversial I don't think red pill
turns men misogynistic at all I don't
think anything that Andrew Tate says
makes men misogynistic at all just like
I know and there have been studies that
prove violent video games do not make
people violent what I do believe however
is that people who are already
misogynistic come into that community
and then they're like here's a
justification for what I believe does
that make sense
yeah so to the point of the angry guys
look I mean anger is a legitimate
response in the face of Injustice it's
okay to get mad there's nothing wrong
with that but what are you going to do
with that anger are you going to sit
there and let it fester and grow within
you and multiply and you know now you
become this enraged ball of like red
anger sort of thing or are you going to
take ownership for the things that you
can control and do something to you know
improve your situation
um you know if you're angry because
women haven't chosen you in the past and
chosen other guys well ask yourself why
right because you're only here today
because your dad your great-grandfather
your great great grandfather you can
keep going down the line somehow figure
it out something that you're Milling
over right now that's not serving you
right so the whole victim mindset bugs
me
um I've never liked it
um you know some people get angry when I
say that you know quitting is like
winners never quit and quitters never
win right so there's lots of times in my
life that I could have quit there's lots
of reasons that I could give you for why
I shouldn't be here today or or whatever
right but I don't adopt the victim
mindset right I adopted the Winner's
mindset and I and I just learned to
like I've always had that I've never sat
back and said F this you know we're done
right like
there's just so many guys today that
haven't that haven't been given the
skill set to deal with things like
rejection you know when we just reject
them or how to do the work in life and
have competency skills like basic
competency skills right
um most guys wouldn't even know how to
check the oil or or change a flat tire
or if something happened to their car on
a road trip and that's when women look
at them like is this guy really the best
I can do like he's like he's got to sit
on the phone and find somebody that can
do this when he's a man and there's a
Tire in the spare trunk and this is a
basic function that my dad could do or
my granddad could do yeah you talked
about that before like women would
constantly be again another evolutionary
this is an evolutionary tool women would
constantly be constantly be checking for
the competency of the man that they're
with correct and I try to explain to
people we go to a plasticine homo sapien
if a woman chooses the wrong partner
it's not I end up with a baby or I end
up with a [__] up story or a crazy
baby's daddy or whatever you die you are
ostracized from the tribe if you picked
the wrong partner and so ten thousand
years ago absolutely exactly not so much
and that's the difference yeah well 50
000 years I mean Homo sapiens about 300
000 years old so seventy thousand years
ago you make that mistake and you die we
came up and I try to explain to people
so hominids are about three million
years old Homo sapiens about 300 000
years old so you think of 300 000 years
and then 11 700 years of agricultural
revolution in that point we're we're now
the apex predator on the planet we can
grow our own food yada yada but from
those first 300 000 years you have to
think every single thing every
predilection we had as Homo sapiens had
to assist in survival 100 if any of them
didn't if you had somebody literally
somebody tears their ACL when they're 15
years old they die they end up getting
killed by whatever Predators around
there and so every single thing that we
had our desired you know fear of snakes
fear of heights fear of spiders you know
those things uh or or the fact that we
like a certain hip to waist ratio facial
symmetry in females and uh signs of
Youth those things had to be selected
for they had to be natural selection for
those things and people don't understand
that so here's 300 000 years of that 11
700 years of agricultural revolution 15
years of Facebook but because of the co
the recency bias we think the world is
Facebook we think the world is has
always been this way and it's the
evolutionary mismatch that causes things
like 80 percent of men on Tinder are
considered unattractive right I feel
like that's where some of this mismatch
comes from
yeah nobody understands The evolutionary
history of desire and attraction and I
think one of the best books that you can
read as a guy is the book it's titled
the evolution of Desire by David Buss
um you're not going to like some of the
stuff that you come across in it but who
cares you know like that's you know if
you have a problem with the facts the
problem is not with the facts so
thinking like you know you have people
today that will get up in the morning
and they'll think that their entire
purpose in life is to go to school get a
degree get graduated uh get a diploma
frame it mahogany go out and get a job
work for a guy like all these things and
it's like Okay the reason why you're
only here is to scatter seed if you're a
guy and if you're a girl the reason why
you're here is to find the best guy that
you can lock down yeah my point is you
can't when I hear people on The View get
away from that yeah when people on The
View are like when are men going to grow
up or when men are like why do women you
know view us uh inadequately or whatever
or they have delusional views of like
what they can get as a woman my whole
thing is I don't blame either side it's
an evolutionary pressure that caused
these things well when they say you know
like on shows like the view like when
are men going to grow up yeah what
they're basically saying is we now have
all these women that have degrees good
jobs can provide for themselves they
don't need no man you know they need a
man like a fish needs a bicycle when are
all the men going to grow up and step up
to wife up all these women and what they
don't understand is the pool of guys
that are above them because women only
date across and up on the socioeconomic
scale because of because of hypergamy
the the pool is small it's not big like
there's not an army of like hundreds of
thousands of men sitting in a dark
corner somewhere hiding from these women
you know and they're just going to grow
up one day and show up that's not how it
works they just don't understand the
Dynamics of it yeah and by the way those
men who are above that level also are
receiving so much attention from women
that the likelihood of those men staying
uh you know monogamous is extremely low
it was a great book have you I don't
know if you've ever read uh Satoshi
kamazawa's first book which was why
beautiful people have more daughters he
wrote another book called the
intelligence Paradox he's been like
almost canceled for both of these books
by the way in the intelligence Paradox
he talks about as people become more
Intel like as you get into higher IQ
stratification they're more likely to
cheat and also there's other studies
that show men are more likely to cheat
as you get higher and higher in the
income Stratus which is like the top one
percent I believe is 545 000 a year in
the United States is you get higher and
higher and that you know this is
something that Myron picks talks about
frequently on fresh and fit where it's
like you want a guy who's six foot two
and makes 550 000 a year the likelihood
of you getting him is low the likelihood
of you locking him down is extremely low
likelihood of you getting him locking
him down and not being with any other
women is astronomically low and this is
just a function and the girls are like
no but it doesn't feel like that should
be true I feel like because I watched
this Disney movie I feel like I deserve
this and feelings that don't have
anything to do with it yeah so there's
two things there so I mean first of all
a man's test of loyalty comes when he's
successful a woman's test of loyalty
comes when a man is unsuccessful right
so that kind of sums up what you just
talked about there the other thing too
with that whole like I feel sort of
thing I'm about to ruin this for you and
your audience tonight so I'm going to
apologize in advance but when you start
paying attention to the language used
between men and women and weaker sort of
soy boy beta males you're going to
notice a women mostly lead with I feel
like I feel like that's not right I feel
like there should be more like that
intelligent men that lead with rational
thought use words like I think okay also
beta male soy boys like the weaker sort
of guys with the Low T they'll also use
a lot of the I feel language too so pay
attention to that because you're going
to hear it everywhere now yeah no
definitely the I feel thing was was
really big I like to lead with I just
read a study that's what I like to do I
think yeah I like to I like to do even
better here's a study of 17 000 women
who were surveyed anonymously here's a
certain facts you hear some facts here's
again I love the GSS survey the one that
says states that 28 percent of men had
zerosexual Partners in the last year and
this was done in 2018. if you look at
the way that scale was going that hockey
stick right now in 2022 we were probably
most likely around 30 to 33 percent of
men have had zerosexual Partners in the
last year now when we look at this when
when I try to explain to people and by
the way some of the some of these are
men also when I try to explain the
concept of hypergamy and how the
hypergamy scale where men are always
going equal or down and women are always
going equal or up when I try to explain
that to them and I get denial I'm like
okay well two irrefutable facts
unassailable facts number one we can see
on Tinder that 80 percent of men are
considered to be unattractive and and
secondly from the GSS survey we can see
that 33 of men are having zerosexual
partners and so this shows this is an
absolutely unassailable irrefutable fact
that we're having a great number of
women
going after a small number of men at the
top and then anecdotally that's where I
come in secondarily like I'm friends
with Dan Bilzerian he's a buddy of mine
I hang out with him it is madness how
many women I literally listen and tell
me you know what I would never do I'd
never have sex with Dan that's always
what they say right before they have sex
with Dad it's one of the craziest things
I've ever said nothing my friend Vegas
Dave it's the same kind of thing right
before they have sex with Vegas they
were like ooh I would never have sex
with Vegas then they do it and it's just
so it's so crazy to me and it's one of
these situations where like I understand
that the world isn't the way you think
it should be but by the way this is not
a function of culture this is another
thing I want to get people to understand
this idea that there's a few guys at the
top getting this when you read about
Mubarak Mubarak the bloodthirsty from I
believe Morocco had 860 kids or
something like that you you smell the
bloodthirsty Ishmael the blood thirsty
I'm sorry yeah and then also you know
yeah uh Genghis Khan in his situation
where like one path of one percent of
all males on the planet have his Y
chromosome this is a fun this is not
something that just started recently
it's just social media has made it to
where there used to be a bifurcation
there used to be be a dating scene in
Wichita and another dating scene in Waco
there used to be a dating scene in
Cheyenne Wyoming in another dating scene
in Chicago New Jersey and now there
isn't that anymore because of social
media they've all sort of pushed into
this one massive dating scene and I the
reason why I bring this up is there's
this girl I used to know I'm still
friends with her name is JoJo van saathi
she's from Wichita Kansas she was a
Hooters waitress there she gets
discovered and she ends up flying out to
uh Los Angeles and she's the first girl
I know to to my knowledge she's the
first girl to hit a million followers on
Instagram I met her when she was 19. and
and since then she's just been traveling
the world doing these magazine covers
she has 10 million followers on
Instagram and my point was there there
was probably an injury attorney or a
cardiologist that lived in Wichita who
was going to marry this girl but she got
pulled to danville's literally Dan
bilzerian's house and because of that
now we have this this stratification
that's happened where there's a few guys
at the top who are showing signs of
signs of Fitness nice cars uh they're
able to be funny the the ability to
Network all these signs of Fitness in
men and these men are having incredible
success and then we have a group of men
that are completely being ignored
yeah it's it's just the reality of the
world man you know like we know that um
the vast majority of women have
reproduced throughout history but I
think something like 25 percent of men
have reproduced throughout history so oh
it's it's for most guys it's a dead end
yeah yeah 25 yeah correct yeah I was
trying to explain this to some people
before because they were like ungrateful
and I was like do you want to realize
before the year 1850 half the Earth's
population died before the age of five
and way way more than 50 of men who've
ever lived out of Virgin way more than
50 yeah and then when they hear that
they're just I had a friend of mine a
female friend I was I kept throwing
these facts at her and her respect her
response was it's not my response your
dick is not my responsibility and I was
like there you go that's my that's the
proof of what I was trying to say before
and then in the end and they're like
well there's no good men and I was like
I know 50 dudes who would go out with
you right now do anything you want but
because you keep seeing the dude with
the lambo you can't you can't what's it
called uh uh recalibrate to understand
what's going on and then you end up next
thing you know you're 40 and you don't
have a relationship you don't kids you
don't have a husband and that's the
reason why yeah and those same 40 year
older women are the ones sitting on The
View talking about you know men need to
you know man up or grow up or whatever
it's like yeah there's no 40 year old
guys that I know that are that are that
are worth their salt that have their
life together that have a nice car great
life lots of money you know influential
they're competent they're interesting
that are dating 40 year old women
they're dating younger hotter women that
that's just what men do I really hope
you guys enjoyed that clip if you want
to watch the full-length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out